por qué
cuáles son tus metas
un día yo le hice esta pregunta a una
amiga mía y me contestó algo que me
llamó mucho la atención decía así
da un poco de miedo pensar en eso no
crees y más en esta etapa en la que
todos esperan que tengas tu vida
completamente planeada en la que todos
esperan que se pase exactamente qué
hacer y te empujen a ser extraordinario
yo no quiero ser extraordinaria solo
quiero ser yo y hacer lo que me gusta la
pregunta me presiona y siento que
necesito tener metas suficientemente
valiosas como para contestar
esta respuesta me dejó reflexionando
mucho
y a partir de ese momento yo dejé de
hacer esta pregunta
porque me hizo darme cuenta de un
problema muy común y muy extendido en
nuestra sociedad que nos está afectando
a todos llamado la presión a ser
extraordinarios a tener que ser alguien
y fue este despertar el que me trajo
este escenario esta noche
con un mensaje muy profundo que me
gustaría compartirles
voy a contar una historia
yo me cambié tres veces de carrera en
tres diferentes universidades
la verdad yo no tenía idea de lo que
quería estudiar ni a lo que me quería
dedicar y me sentía perdido y me sentía
muy angustiado pero sobre todo yo me
sentía juzgado
me sentía juzgado por no saber
exactamente lo que yo quería ser de mi
vida a mis 18 años cuando por cierto
nadie lo sabe y nadie tiene por qué
saber
pero a mí me daba vergüenza reconocer
eso me daba vergüenza reconocer que la
neta no que no tenía un plan que me
había cambiado tres veces de carrera y
que mis gustos e intereses nada más no
encajaban dentro de lo normal en muchas
ocasiones esto me hizo sentir fuera de
lugar
y entonces un día se me ocurrió la
brillante idea de empezar a mentir y
empezar a mentir acerca de mis planes y
de lo que yo realmente quería hacer para
que la gente me dejara en paz
y entonces cuando llega a una persona y
me preguntaba otra vez que hoy él y así
y como que quieres estudiar yo agarraba
me como me volteaba le contestaba su
ingeniería a mí bueno eso es lo de hoy a
poco has visto un ingeniero muerto de
hambre oye oye lee así como que creo que
a qué te quieres dedicar
es mi win a la construcción y en eso es
lo de hoy nuevo bueno no mejor mejor la
construcción no eso ya está ya está muy
usado mejor otra cosa que les guste
medicina voy a ser doctor
con que doctores
mira nomás lo abusado que saliste allí y
no tienes novia porque tengo una hija
híjole guapísima
guapísima pero si yo agarraba y llegaba
y les decía oye qué crees que estudió
música no no hermano ya ya todas mis
hijas están casadas ya aquí aquí ya ni
le busques
se dan cuenta
y en un intento más desmedido de dejar
de ser juzgado de dejar de sentirme
avergonzado
cumplir con las exigencias de la
sociedad yo estúpidamente me metí de
inicio estudiar finanzas porque claro
ese plan sonaba realista maduro nada de
estatus y me sentí importante
así fue como yo me gané el respeto pero
pero yo estaba profundamente angustiado
estaba muy angustiado
porque me había dejado arrastrar por una
poderosa marea
por un fenómeno social al que yo le
llamo la marea de las exigencias
si se dan cuenta queridos amigos vivimos
en una sociedad llena de presiones y
exigencias no sea el mejor esfuérzate no
te equivoques haz las cosas bien
ten un plan con los pies en la tierra
trabaja duro gana mucho dinero y llega
muy lejos
somos constantemente sacudidos y
arrastrados por una marea de exigencias
ajenas en esencia por esta presión hacer
seres humanos extraordinarios a tener
que ser alguien en la vida
y tristemente queridos amigos así es
como hemos aprendido a valorar a la
gente
por sus logros por sus títulos por sus
capacidades por su profesión e incluso
por el grosor de su cuenta bancaria
pero no por sus valores ni por su
capacidad de amar y simplemente conectar
con otros seres humanos
entre más rindes más te aprueban entre
más lejos llegas más te reconoce
asociamos la inteligencia y la madurez
de la gente con las carreras que eligen
estudiar e incluso aquello a lo que se
dedican y los juzgamos en base a sus
metas y qué tan ambiciosas son
y desgraciadamente esta mala costumbre
ha marcado una línea muy fina entre los
que supuestamente si somos importantes o
somos alguien en la vida
y pues los que no
y muchas veces es esta creencia de que
tenemos que ser extraordinarios ya que
nos agobian tanto
y nos descarrile y nos arrastra por
caminos iniciados como a mí me sucedió
pero les traigo dos buenas noticias y la
primera de ellas amigos es que no
tenemos que cumplir con estas exigencias
porque resulta que cumplir o no con
ellas no es nuestra obligación sino más
bien nuestra elección y se los voy a
demostrar
quiero que hagamos un pequeño ejercicio
saleh
quiero que nos tomemos por favor un
momento para pensar en todas estas cosas
en las que nos sentimos presionados o
exigidos piensen en el trabajo los
estudios la familia su pareja y
simplemente pregúntense de que me siento
presionado o presionada o agobiado o
agobiada
estas son el tipo de declaraciones con
las que yo usualmente me topo cuando
este ejercicio con nuestra gente y si se
dan cuenta la mayoría de ellas
inconscientemente las empezamos con la
palabra tengo que no tengo que ser el
mejor tengo que llegar muy lejos
tengo que trabajar muy duro tengo que
tengo que
pero realmente tenemos que
ahora quiero que por favor le pongamos
un signo de interrogación a todas estas
declaraciones
tengo que ser el mejor tengo que
trabajar muy duro tengo que llegar muy
lejos
y finalmente creo que borremos ahora la
palabra tengo que y la reemplacemos por
quiero
quiero ser el mejor
quiero llegar muy lejos
quiero trabajar muy duro
quiero casarme y tener hijos
quizás no
pero se dan cuenta cómo cambia todo
cuando planteamos las cosas de esta
forma
como esta soltamos esta carga y mejora
la manera en la que nos sentimos
queridos amigos el fundamento de este
ejercicio es que nos demos cuenta como
sólo basta con replantear estas
declaraciones de esta forma para
transformar las exigencias en una serie
de elecciones para retomar el poder y el
control de elegir lo que queremos hacer
y ser y lo que no queridos amigos y
amigas no tenemos la obligación de ser
extraordinarios no tenemos la obligación
de cumplir con estas exigencias ni de
ser alguien en la vida ni de nada más
que los está agobiando porque cumplir o
no con ello no es una obligación sino
más bien nuestra elección
y si es nuestra elección cumplir o no
con estas exigencias
entonces también lo es elegir si nos
agobiamos o no por ellas se dan cuenta
y si hay algo que me ha costado a mi
trabajo aprender a lo largo en mi vida
es eso que la presión y las exigencias
no vienen de afuera
y en los papás y en los amigos y en los
estudios y el trabajo sino más bien de
nosotros mismos
porque somos nosotros quienes al final
del día nos estamos poniendo son las
exigencias quiénes estamos eligiendo
arrastrarnos junto con la marea
y no me parece lógico a gobiernos por
algo que nosotros mismos estamos
eligiendo hacer
y con esto también le contesto a mi
querida amiga del principio y a todos
ustedes si en sus planes no está ser
extraordinarios y será alguien en la
vida nadie tiene por qué serlo y se vale
claro que se vale
esa no es una obligación
los últimos ya con esta carga
pero es difícil convencer a la gente de
esto y aquí es donde se pone más
interesante porque me ha tocado mucha
gente que viene y me dice es quería
hacer es que yo no estoy de acuerdo
contigo yo no estoy de acuerdo contigo
porque no se supone que a la vida si
venimos a lograr cosas que a la vida
vinimos a cumplir con nuestros objetivos
a trascender y ser alguien en la vida
y mi respuesta hoy en día es
a la vida no vinimos
a lograr cosas
y a trascender
y hacer a alguien
y a cumplir con ningún objetivo
y sé que esto que estoy diciendo a
muchos lo saca de onda y no los culpo
porque a mí también me costó mucho
trabajo transformar esta creencia y
aprender esta poderosísima lección
que como un día me dijo un querido
mentor y amigo mío
agustín mier y terán
a la vida no vinimos a lograr cosas
sino más bien a vivir intentando
lograrlas
y esta es la segunda buena noticia que
viene a darles el día de hoy
fíjense bien nada más que poderosa
lección
si el único propósito de la vida es
simplemente vivir entonces ya no tenemos
que preocuparnos tanto por lograr porque
que cree en eso no nos hace más ni menos
importantes ni más ni menos exitosos ni
mejores ni peores seres humanos si el
único propósito de la vida es
simplemente vivir entonces que nos hace
pensar que por lograr cosas estamos un
escalón más arriba que los demás que el
valor de un ser humano se define por sus
victorias que podemos agarrar el
currículum de los demás y hojear lo y
con ello determinar si son o no alguien
en la vida con todo el respeto qué forma
más patética de valorar un ser humano
yo también juzgado hacia la gente
y yo también me juzgaba así a mí mismo
pero si algo estoy seguro es que detrás
de ese camino solo vamos a encontrar un
camino tapizado de arrogancia
el valor de un ser humano no está en sus
títulos ni en sus logros ni en sus
capacidades ni siquiera en su
inteligencia
pero estamos muy acostumbrados a ver la
vida así
a ver la vida como una montaña no como
una lucha constante para llegar a la
cima si lo logramos entonces fuimos
exitosos y si no entonces fracasamos una
de dos y a través de esos ojos la vida
no suele ser tan divertida
estamos muy obsesionados con esta idea
de alcanzar el éxito
creo que si el propósito de la vida
amigos nunca fuese que si el objetivo
final nunca ha sido lograr nada sino más
bien vivir intentando lograrlo
porque no nos hemos planteado esa
posibilidad
amigos a la vida no vinimos a ser
extraordinarios eso que más da pero no
importantes no da la felicidad por favor
no nos agobiemos más por esto
no dejemos que el ego nos engañe nos
descarrile yo tome decisiones por ello y
lo único que no encontré fue orgullo
detrás de eso
dejemos ya de juzgar a la gente y de
juzgarnos a nosotros mismos por nuestras
victorias por nuestras conquistas en la
vida dejemos ya de hacer girar nuestra
vida alrededor de nuestros logros y
mejor hagamos la gira alrededor de
nuestros intentos de nuestras
experiencias buenas o malas
si al final resulta que cumplimos con
nuestros objetivos bien y sino que creen
también
porque de todas formas ese nunca fue el
propósito
los invito a honrar sus intentos no sus
resultados honremos el único propósito
de la vida que es simplemente vivir
claro
ocupémonos de ello pero lograr los
amigos
y lograr es solo un complemento
secundario
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]